remember Ronnie said he was not gonna go
to the zoom cocktail party yeah because
everyone was saying he was such a pain
in the ass and commenting on him guess
who went to the zoom cocktail party I
sat and thought about it and I said to
myself why should I let one [ __ ] keep
me away from hanging out now who was it
that used the [ __ ] yeah I don't want
to even acknowledge him oh hey Mike I
decided to join happy hour I almost
thought maybe I shouldn't go but the
second he gets on every line out of his
mouth is everybody be careful what you
say you don't want to offend anybody and
finally I just bid and I said Ronnie
what the [ __ ] man like can we just be
normal here Ronnie why are you even mad
at Mike again I don't even remember I
came on happy hour supposedly his
girlfriend was walking by in the
background and heard me yell some [ __ ]
that supposedly offended her then he
made a whole big [ __ ] deal about it
and then sends me a text message right
afterwards oh don't worry about it
it's nothing she's not offended we're
just joking around blah blah blah but
made me sound like a total [ __ ] at
the time so he could go [ __ ] himself
I'll tell you from my perspective okay
and then he's running around telling me
I'm a big bully [ __ ] you man I don't
have to talk to you Ron he's just gonna
keep monologuing and I'm not gonna be
able to say hey talk be my guest all
right does that interrupt here's my
version of a best Friday the happy hour
thing nobody was that upset right Monday
then on the air
Wilding goes on and talks about what
happened it's not the zoom happy hour
it's the Ronny hour
Ronny is the star of the show and if
anyone tries to steal Ronnie's thunder
they get thrown completely under the
Ronnie hurricane I thought it got a
little extra being towards Ronnie you
know he's a he's a he's a dope but it
made him seem extra dopey so then I tent
of attacks after the show saying like
hey dude I'm not that upset I even said
hey it's [ __ ] Fox I felt like maybe I
contributed to what happened on Monday
and I said Rachel was not offended well
I wouldn't call Ronnie a dope I mean
that's a little strong I was a little
extra dopey yeah I'm a little extra
doping do I have it right that the zoom
party when Ronnie signed on his head on
zoom was right next to your head and
Ronnie said it's making me [ __ ] sick
that I'm
next to Mike Fox that's what makes me
think maybe I really hurt him and he
does think I'm this [ __ ] snake well I
don't think I am Ronnie did you use to
like Mike or was it always I but no no
Kim now you don't like him
no I don't like do you want to hear
Ralph's take on this because he is
there's a little revisionist going on
here and here's what happened
somebody brought up that mr. Ronnie show
Ronnie's an [ __ ]
and then Mike Fox jumps in with an
example of Ronnie being an [ __ ] so
[ __ ] Mike Fox I'm with Ronnie if you
don't like it why aren't you angry at
the person that recorded you without you
knowing about yeah who did that
I have no idea here's the problem with
Mike he's an annoying kid in high school
who pokes the bear pokes the bear and
then when the bully hits him he cries a
foul like he's the victim and that's
what I think Ronnie is objecting to yeah
psychology analyst yeah learn where you
work take the [ __ ] like everybody else I
can take the [ __ ] no you can't you cried
like a [ __ ] baby last week hey small
hawk it was Tuesday we were fine it was
supposed to be fun it's not supposed to
be this well that's part of the deal I
want to say something I'll remind you
that Ronnie hated JD so much at one
point
JD canceled Ronnie's car show but I will
tell you this now they're like best
friends who did go with to pick up his
engagement ring Ronnie
so Mike there is hope for you and Ronnie
why are you laughing Ronnie I just felt
like laughing I'm not a lot of laugh no
but what did you thought about that from
KP
buddy let me understand something
what is tharok want now come on and
defend your best friend come on no I'm
not defending anybody all I'm saying is
I am the person who started zoom happy
hour for the staff we break our balls
working nine to five five days a week at
five o'clock everybody's supposed to
turn it off and just kick back and have
fun but all three of you [ __ ] Stooges
are ruining it because [ __ ] record
everybody and then sneak it back onto
the answer radio show you dumb [ __ ] okay
it's for the air dude everything with
you is for the air and that's why you're
not your friend anymore
I don't care I don't need friends like
Ralph and I certainly don't need a
friend like you you go [ __ ] yourself you
will say or do anything to get so you
constantly I think Derrick Chris Mike
Fox and Ronnie should be the only ones
at the happy hour this project and it
should be recorded each one of you I
value yeah well you may not like each
other
we love you all that's right Robin and I
look